[موسيقى]
ستستضيف إيطاليا كأس رايدر لأول مرة على الإطلاق
في عام 2023، وهناك لاعب إيطالي واحد
يهدف إلى الحصول على مكانه في فريق أوروبا،
وأحب أن أكون في روما للمنافسة على
كأس رايدر لتمثيل أوروبا، وقد
جعله هذا
اللاعب قد تعلمه العالم 25  يبلغ من العمر عامًا
يقيم الآن في دبي ويقوم
بجولة منذ عدة سنوات ولكن لا يزال هناك
الكثير مما يمكن أن يجعل الشاب الإيطالي
يشعر بالحنين إلى الوطن، فما الذي يفتقده أكثر من غيره، هناك
الكثير، هناك الكثير من
الطعام محلي الصنع والقماش الذي
أفضّله وهذا ما  الطبق الحقيقي
موجود في المنطقة النموذجية التي
تذهب إليها للتو في
مطعم صغير أو في
منزل جدتي وكل شيء لذيذ بينما
ولد ميجليازي ونشأ في إيطاليا
كان أمريكيًا أشعل ناره من أجل
رياضة تايجر وودز التي
أشاهدها دائمًا  تايجر وودز أتذكر أنه
كان لدي كتاب يشبه كتاب تايجر وودز لذا
كان مثلي الأعلى وبدأت بلعب الجولف
ومشاهدة الجولف بسببه
ميجليازي هو الفائز ثلاث مرات في
الجولة الأوروبية بما في ذلك أكبر فوز في
مسيرته في بطولة مفتوحة  دي فرانس في
سبتمبر، انتصار شمل
على الأرجح لقطة الموسم مع
اقترابه من الملكة الثامنة عشرة يوم الأحد
حيث كانت البطولة على المحك [
موسيقى]
أداء ميليوتسي للفوز في
فرنسا أضاف إلى الضجيج حول
دعوة محتملة-  جاهز لكأس رايدر، وهو
حدث حيث يتوقع الإيطالي من
مواطنيه أن يخلقوا
جوًا كهربائيًا مجنونًا، أود أن أقول جنونًا
بصراحة، لا أعلم أنني كنت أتجه نحو
سمكة شبوط رايدر واحدة فقط ولم تكن في
أوروبا بل كانت في أمريكا
وكان فيلدينغ كذا وكذا
لأن الأمريكيين
فظون لكنك تعلم أنني أكتب الكوب هو
الكوب الصحيح، لذا فهو رائع وجميل
بسبب ذلك،
لذا في إيطاليا ليس لدي أي فكرة ولكن آه
أود أن أرى ذلك بالداخل
الحبال